you need to start something like you
need to start becoming good at something
instead of just jumping around trying to
make a quick but it kind of just has
that niche if you like taking things
apart building things putting things
together but also using your brain it's
a really good job the best money that
you can make the best opportunities like
me I'm a youtuber now I do this
full-time I've two YouTube channels on I
love it but it wouldn't have happened if
I wouldn't have put tools on thirteen
years ago and started learning something
so I know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about gonna screw guys before we start
this video I want to do a quick
announcement sorry about this Dustin
told me in the middle of our interview
about this channel Sparky's channel
there's a guy called Sparky Channel I'm
so sorry to cut you off know there's a
guy named his name is Bill but it's
Sparky Channel something happened to him
recently I've been getting a lot of
questions what happened to all your
videos why can't I find my favorite
Sparky Channel video I got an email that
appeared to be from YouTube but it
wasn't it was from a hacker he had like
a hundred and eighty thousand followers
on YouTube have you ever heard of this
somebody's YouTube account gets hacked
they lose all their videos and all their
subscribers it's very much like an email
that they clicked on a link it was a
hacking a phishing scam yeah yeah how
the hell can they how can they clean out
your YouTube though this dude lost a
hundred and eighty some thousand
subscribers lost like hundreds and
hundreds where's his channel why didn't
he get his channel back their privacy
I've been adding a lot this had been
happening a lot but people have been
getting it their channel back well he's
an older dude so he's deaf he's retired
probably late 60s early 70s so the
technology barrier is not there but I've
been saying like whatever I needed you
yeah I really order normally I so if you
guys like what we do here if you're a
member of the army I want you if you
have a twitter go retweet this tweet you
team YouTube unfortunately only pays
attention to support tweets if you get a
ton of retweets and likes so please go
blow that up and the other thing you can
do is go sind
Sparky some love this is just absolutely
devastating
and the YouTube community needs to come
together anytime this happens it scares
the hell out of me I'll tell you that
much
but thanks Dustin for bringing that to
my attention and night on with the video
today I have Dustin Stelzer guys he's an
electrician the biggest electrician on
YouTube I think possibly maybe he runs a
channel called both journey to master
and electrician you where he took
basically documents his his journey as
an electrician tells you everything you
need to know everything from tutorials
that just kind of insider life talk but
guys you know what this shows about it's
about real jobs real jobs that you can
find if you're out there you're tired of
the Guru bubble and you want to go find
something real Dustin introduced us to
what being an electrician is all about
how'd you find it
etc okay so I was always one of those
people that was chasing the hustle
trying to chase the get-rich-quick thing
oh I know man like since I was a kid I
had a kid when I was a kid you know I
like I hit college I went and tried
college a couple different things and
just made some decisions that forced
meets you have to figure something out
on the fly and so I was always like I
don't know I had all these like side
businesses and everything and I went
into the corporate world and I went
through a lot of schooling I was flying
planes you know aviation it was really
really expensive for college and just
like wasting time and wasting money
trying to make all of these it's like
overnight things happen and the I got
laid off I was working at Dell computers
and I got laid off and that was a huge
hit like I lost a car that I had was
making payments all this stuff on so my
whole lifestyle changed and my dad was
like dude you need to start something
like you need to start becoming good at
something instead of just jumping around
trying to make a quick buck like learn a
skill and so I always went on job sites
with him he was a handyman and
concrete word like he'd have me doing
tile and putting doors and windows and
stuff like that just working with tools
every day and it was never something
that I thought I would want to do but it
was always cool [ __ ] doing it with him
just getting to mess with tools and
learn how things are built so he had a
buddy that was an electrician and we
were actually doing a tile job at his
house and like he came in the door he's
like hey you guys hire an electricians
and he's like yeah we are and he looked
at me was I go interview for this job
and so I did I went and talked to the
boss and I got a job I'm like write that
in there and I started day one had some
tools and ever since I've been doing it
had you ever done anything like that
before
no I mean other than helping my dad like
I had done some construction stuff but
it was just again it was like I found a
recruiting ad and it was like this is
the highest pay by paying like cheap
thing that I can get to you really
quickly and so I did it for a few months
but but no this was like my first ever
real construction gig how fast did you
realize oh this is cool this is
something I want to do obviously you've
fallen in love with it by now
at what point when did you find this how
old were you when you found this because
you were young you had a kid you jumped
around jobs how when when did you kind
of find this trade when I was 22 so I'm
34 about to be 35 in a month it's about
13 years now it's the only thing that
I've ever done for a long time I mean
I've worked restaurants like golf
courses I was a chef I did retail like
I've done every kind of job you can
imagine because I've always had to work
two to three jobs like you know child
support and take care of all of that so
I have a lot of different things that
I've done but this is a first thing that
like day one I was like this is dope
like I want to do this and like the more
I did it you know after a couple years I
started to know what I was doing
becoming good at what I was doing and I
was like hell yeah there's like a
lifelong career this isn't just a job
you know this is this is something with
staying power and it's something where
you can build a skill that is a hard to
outsource hard to replace right I mean
like you you have a real skill at this
point people can't just hire anybody to
do what you do
yeah being an electrician is very day
Duras you know at times it's also it's
one of the highest-paid trades because
you have to have a lot of mental acuity
you have to be able to figure out
problems somewhat dangerous problems at
times too so there's a lot of math and
theoretical science involved in
electricity so it kind of just has that
niche if you like taking things apart
building things putting things together
but also using your brain it's a really
good job do you now do you work for
somebody
what's the career path of an electrician
like so you get into it you don't know
anything
somebody just gives you a job and you're
like an electrician or you're not in a
procure an apprentice or yeah so so when
people look at me and I'm bizarre
because I do so many different things
within our industry your first question
was do you work for somebody yes I work
for myself I have my own company I also
work for another company and consult and
do stuff and they let me film out on job
sites and I am a professor a
professional a full-time youtuber so I
have a lot of different opportunities
because I've taken a decade or more to
learn about a craft and become really
good at it but as far as like your your
next question starting out you have to
apprentice so whether you choose to go
into the Union and go through their
training programs and start working in
the Union or if you go non-union which
basically you just call somebody say hey
are you hiring and show up they want and
you're trained on the job those are the
two main options there is trade school
as well but I don't really recommend
that to most people unless you just
don't have any other options and you
can't find a job it's a good thing to
try to get some schooling in the
meantime you don't recommend trades
close that's interesting I don't most of
them are scams not scams they're their
middlemen that are unnecessary and they
take a lot of money so there are some
trade schools out there that are really
really great and when I say great I mean
they actually give you experience you
wear tools you do things and pretend
you're you're an electrician and then
you go into classes and they break all
of the science and the understanding
down and teach you code but it's kind of
this whole process so that once you get
out and you're sitting there in front of
me a master electrician
can say I have some experience I've
actually gone to this school and I know
what I'm doing but the problem is most
trade schools out there just teach from
a classroom so these kids after a year
or two get out to a job and master
electrician's like alright what can you
do and they're like I don't know I've
never wore tools but I've gone through
the certification and none of us care
like we literally don't give a [ __ ] what
Community College you took an
electricity class from it does not
matter can you wear tools and boss-ass
and making money that's all I think
that's one of the most the biggest
disconnects between people and knowing
how to get into a trade they think that
they need the middleman to give them
permission to do the job they think
basically they need permission from some
guy they have some certificate that says
I can do this job what you're telling me
is if let's say you're trying to hire
somebody you're not necess of paper no I
don't give a [ __ ] man there's people
that have like engineering degrees and
they're like I would be a great
electrician like I don't give a [ __ ]
you're getting paid the same as that
sixteen-year-old kid who's never wore
tools I don't care what paper you've got
it's all about experience and the as you
go and get experience and you know how
to use these tools and apply the job
that we do then getting schooling on top
of that is great because it gains
perspective and it makes you able to
hone your craft a little bit wiser with
some depth so maybe it's worth getting
on-the-job training then going to school
later maybe on the side as you do it to
get that back in knowledge yeah or you
know one of the great things about the
Union is the Union does both at the same
time so you go out and you work for the
field they send you to school every so
often every couple of months you have to
go take a few classes but they kind of
keep you in both environments and build
that knowledge and that's mandatory in
the union with non-union it's not
necessarily mandatory I never had any
classes that I had to go to I've just
been like digging through books because
I love this [ __ ] it's so interesting
yeah so I've got a kind of random
question and this is as an aside as
someone who's completely afraid of
getting shocked
what's it'll it what's the most
dangerous situation on electrician can
be in because obviously it's people
normally think like myself it's all
about volts and I
heard that that's not entirely true but
what's a dangerous situation versus not
a dangerous situation because I assume
all shocks are kind of equally
terrifying what do you what are you
worried about as an electrician I mean
it seemed dangerous obviously you know
what you're doing but yeah I'm worried
about not having my full attention on
what I'm doing that and also I'm afraid
when people trust what other people have
said there's been a there's been times
where I have been electrocuted because I
trusted that somebody said the power was
off and I just went in and put my hands
in and phone got lit up really bad so I
don't care if I'm a master electrician
working with a 30 or 40 year master
electrician if he says the powers of
them I don't care man I'm pulling my
meat my meter out I don't trust anything
that people say in the field that I know
like I trust everybody I'm a very
trusting individual but with power it's
just not trust but verify
there you go so it's it's being
electrician is kind of weighing risk and
there's never too many there's never a
good enough reason to risk your life and
there's a lot of cowboys out there
there's a lot of electricians that are
like I just do it hot it doesn't matter
you know and they'll stick their hands
in and and I've done that a lot as well
I work live on a lot of things there's
just some times where you have to you
but you're always trying to minimize
your risk and when people are not paying
attention when they're off thinking
about an argument they had with their
brother or you know they're just not
focused that scares me as well because
that's when accidents happen an
accidents can be you know stubbing your
toe but accidents can also be like
literally you just touch something and
all of a sudden your body's a black
charred mess and you're gone you're not
on this planet anymore I mean it's that
fast that you die so put that in
perspective when you think about dealing
with or treat but you don't owe you
don't always die right like what makes a
shock deadly verse not deadly
well it's there's a lot of different
things so how much current is going
through your body what the voltage of
that circuit is as well as how much
resistance you offer to the surf because
you know we're made of skin so we're
made of we have a certain kind of
resistance to oppose the flow of current
you're really really wet you're not that
resistive anymore that stuff's gonna go
through you like crazy so every single
electrocution is different because every
circuit is different in every situation
that you're in is different so I've
gotten shocked between my you know
across my fingers which the current
travels through your heart and they say
that that's the most dangerous way to
get shocked you know if I get shocked
from like a wire touching here to
another wire touching here it's only
gonna go through here but if you get
shocked at a really really low current
you know the the likelihood of you dying
is not as possible as it is a high
current so you could get shocked like
I've been shocked in a 9,000 volt neon
sign transformer and everybody's like
holy crow well big number number yeah it
was a fraction of an amp it was so small
that it just felt like a like a digital
spiderweb on my hand it was really
bizarre feeling huh that's that's so
interesting I find I find it kind of
fascinating but back to the career stuff
I just wanted to know cuz I've always
kind of like wondered and I'm sure a lot
of people have wondered what it's like
getting shocked but actually one more
question are Tate do tasers are tasers
dangerous at all I assume they're not is
it just they do high voltage is super
low amperage is that how they work
that's the whole idea yeah it's such a
high voltage and there's things that we
use there's like these little pratas
that we can test to see if like a neon
sign you know all those pretty neon
signs if if there's a problem with them
and they won't ignite we have this
little thing it's got 15,000 volts on
that we can stick it up to that thing
and ignite it and make it light up and
will when nobody's looking at OSHA's not
around there have been times where
people have gone around and just knocked
each other with it and you know it's
like an electric fence if you've ever
touched an electric fence ash it hurts
but yeah yeah you kill you
right right huh interesting
interesting good to know alright so um
so so so get it getting on with it
you're hired
you're like you're moving up the ranks
but there's this whole ladder you have
to climb right so you're an apprentice
how does that work so how long do you
have to work to be an apprentice and
what are you getting paid like I know
I'm sure it varies but give people an
idea of what you think what you can
expect and what you usually advise
people to look
okay so yeah you have to apprentice it's
like the whole Star Wars you know Jedi
apprentice master thing but basically
you are stuck with a person or you might
rotate around to learning under
different people for four years some
states it's five years it just kind of
depends some unions some states all that
a little bit different but there's a
minimum hours that you have to clear so
for me in Texas we have a two-year
license which is called a residential
wireman I mean that you can run
residential jobs you're not doing
anything big and industrial or anything
crazy like that but you can wire house
and so that's four thousand hours and
they only give you two thousand a year
so you have to have two full years of
experience I see yeah and then the next
license after that is the unrestricted
journeyman which means you're able to
work everywhere it's four years or eight
thousand hours and then a lot of people
just get that license and they're good
for the rest of their career that's all
they want to do but then there's if you
want to run a business you have to
become a master electrician what's the
difference pretty much you get to pull
permits it's about it there's not a
whole lot of difference there's a lot of
people even say it's really unnecessary
you're gonna get a master electricians
license unless you want to run a company
huh well it's kinda nice to have the
title though master's dad's a lot cooler
than journeyman but it really just means
I passed a more hard or more difficult
test okay so it just comes down to test
and probably some hours requirements huh
yeah because in Texas the law is that
somebody has to take the liability for
all of the people working in the trade
on a job and it has to have one person
that's the master electrician they own
the company all the insurances in their
name all the liability everything so
they're taking all the risks so it needs
to be somebody and they call them a
master electrician so all the reward but
although all the risk - yeah it got it
got it got it got it
how much so so sorry I think we also I
want to address how much money do you
make as an electrician roughly it man it
varies like here I've heard of people
making $13 an hour starting out as an
apprentice to making fifteen or sixteen
you know it depends on the job market
really
and then for journeyman you're probably
again here in Austin you're looking
around twenty four to thirty five
depending on you know if you're like a
foreman or anything like that there's a
lot of different reasons why your number
would be different if you're Union
you're gonna have a number that's very
similar to everybody else around you
because it's kind of like the military
where it's just based off of rank not
necessary not necessarily bear it out
with merit so they call non-union
workers they call them merit workers
because I can negotiate my pay I can go
talk to my boss and be like yo man I've
been working really hard for you the
last two years I haven't asked you for a
raise and I can do motor controls I knew
that all this stuff now I want this wage
and you'd be like okay yeah let's talk
about it so there's a little bit more
flexibility but you're oftentimes doing
a lot smaller work and you're not
working with you know three hundred
people you're working mom-and-pop thing
and you're doing you know smaller type
jobs we're in residential stuff and yeah
whereas in the Union II they have a lot
of like big hospitals and you know
stadiums and stuff like that they get
that work so alright so you you're in
the trade you've kind of like found your
passion and let's say someone's in
what's your favorite thing to do now
what's your favorite part what gets you
up in the morning and gets you excited
to go to work
filming what I do every day interesting
guy okay so I had one done because I
would say you're doing the same thing
you're just putting a camera on it yeah
so I have to work twice as hard because
I have to drag cameras around me
everywhere and to get a job done in a
timely fashion and not lose money on it
so to me that's the challenge
I love teaching like my my favorite
thing is to have a brand new apprentice
and spend a lot of time with them over a
really long period of time and teaching
them and seeing each time they do
something seeing that little like light
bulb like oh my god I just need that
work
and like you know they'll come up to me
to be like dude look at all the conduit
I just bent like it looks so pretty you
know and just having those aha moments
and helping somebody find their that's
what I love so that's why I do an
electrician you is really a record a lot
of this stuff and I try to Tiana's
nobody else is doing it so let's say I
think probably my big biggest
demographic that I'm trying to reach
with this series and people that I'm
trying to hopefully help are people that
get emails from all the time they are
out of high school they didn't want to
go to college or they dropped out of
college because it just wasn't right for
them they tried this make money online
e-commerce hustle obviously a lot of
it's a scam cuz as your father said
rightly you're not really building a
skill in a lot of cases you're trying to
maybe ride a wave or something like that
so now they they want to find a real job
and they're wondering is an electrician
right for me they have no idea what what
do you what have you found are there any
like commonalities with electricians
anything you find that like they're all
interested in this or who do you think
would be a good make a good electrician
dude
anybody anybody I like no BS so this is
my fourth year that I've been doing this
thing online so I'm connected with a lot
of electricians through the years and
the one thing that I think I've gotten
the most often is years ago and even
today I get people that say hey I'm 42
hey I'm 60 hey I'm 27 is it too late to
be an electrician and I'm like no dude
try it out and they're most of them are
like I got a degree in this or I'm going
to school for this because my parents
want me to do this but I hate it and I
really want to try something in the
trades I want to I like putting things
together and taking things apart and I
have the brain for that and so if
anything is a commonality a little bit
of mechanical mindedness like liking
science because electricity is not an
actual thing that you can see
electricity is an invisible force so
it's so weird it's like manipulating the
wind it's like we're or wind workers but
electricity instead they just pitch
that's a good pitch for like an
electrician man
The Last Airbender yeah álast electric
bender yeah so I mean it's you got to
have a little bit of aptitude somebody
that if you're really super lazy and you
just want to like smoke bowls and watch
Netflix all day long like this is not
the job for you no for real I didn't got
nothing wrong but you you've got to
actually have a hustle you got to be
able to work hard the people that you're
working around every day will respect
hard work they're not gonna respect
somebody sitting on their phone sneaking
off to the bathroom for you know a 20
minute break to like talk to their wife
like you're there to work and busting
ass is it currency on these job sites
and the more people are able to bust ass
and do really well they have more
currency and get further one thing that
I will I wish was taught to people is
that if you want to work with your hands
the trades are the way to do it it's
what I keep hearing is so I went and I
became a chemical engineer and I hated
it and one of the reasons I sort of
hated it was I realized my future was
probably in some chemical plant trying
to operate efficiencies and I'm managing
a bunch of guys you know but the odds
that I'm actually gonna do stuff in the
field especially is used in a Senate
corporation it's very it's very low I
mean you're kind of like the big picture
guy mm-hmm and I kind of I did not know
that going to school I thought oh yeah
I'd be able to do all this stuff
Chemical Engineering it's basically
chemistry right and like or or no it's
not you're not that guy you're the guy
in the black in them I'm gonna copy out
real quick because everyone's gonna
blame me for this in most cases you're
not the guy no bro you can't get a jump
okay I know but uh but the people it's
rare it's true it's so rare that you're
gonna be a 50% 50% guy and get to go out
in the field
yeah the time and get to install the
materials no that's the same thing with
electrical engineering I was gonna go
into electrical engineering and be a
master electrician and an EE but it's
like no I'm gonna sit and do is being a
cubicle doing [ __ ] calculations for
someone else to go install it right
right and if you want to be that guy
installing if you like as you said
getting your hands dirty which I feel
like a lot of a lot of dudes that I've
met do like that they do like getting
their hands dirty because it's something
real they can like feel and I mean even
though you can't feel electricity you
can feel what you're working with and at
the end of the day if you install lights
in a residential place that's a tangible
thing you can point to and say hey I did
that yeah whereas it's a little more
abstract when you're you know just like
working it within some electrical
diagram diagramming software and you're
like oh what did I really contribute I'm
not really as sure yeah so for me I
always loved it like hands-on stuff but
I kind of felt cheated getting out of
school realizing that my jobs were not
doing that at all so something that I
love about the trades is they give that
avenue for people that like that stuff
it's like hey you can do that and you
can one day move into the office but as
long as you want to be out there you can
be out there yeah I tried I have one
video that I think was probably my
earliest hitting video that got a lot of
traffic and it was why you should be an
electrician and it was just me sit in my
truck talking about the pros and cons of
not knowing what you want to do with the
rest of your life and choosing to go pay
a college to figure that out or to go
try some [ __ ] and figure it out and you
know with being an electrician or being
a plumber you're paid to learn you show
up every day and they give you money to
make mistakes and to learn for years and
by the time you get done with four years
you have an eight hour a day forty to
fifty hour a week job for years like you
have thousands of hours of doing the
[ __ ] that you're gonna do while you're
being schooled every day whereas if you
go to college you're gonna pay out the
ass to take humanities and US history
and all the [ __ ] that doesn't matter and
once you graduate you're you really
don't have that much experience in the
trade you just prove that you can stick
with something for four years but once
you get out and go to a job you're still
gonna have to have all this other
training or go to oh yeah on-the-job
training is unreal especially like if
you're I mean some some people say and I
kind of agree whenever I say I'm a
chemical engineer they're like well you
never
actually because I went basically
straight into YouTube and they're like
yeah
being an engineer does it really even
start until you get the job because all
four years [ __ ] you dude so insane I
literally got that like degree because
my parents like you have to do something
consistent that you could get a job and
if you wanted and even after I realized
I didn't want to do it I was like let me
just get this out of the way let me
finish it so that I'll always have
something to fall back on but but no but
no I agree like the real training for
being like a professional engineer
really starts when you're on the job and
so and that's four years after you've
already paid a bunch of money to get
into it and so like the big advantage of
trades is as you said number one you
don't go way in debt with an
unforgivable loan and number two you're
learning on the job what you're actually
gonna be doing yeah tell people why they
shouldn't be an electrician why
shouldn't they be
give me a reason that they like so we've
talked about the good things maybe you
said it I mean like if you don't want to
be lazy but are there any other things
that you see like you won't stick with
it if you have if you are this way yeah
an electrician in general if you if you
don't like sweating and you don't like
like no no [ __ ] we work hard we lift
heavy things we cut ourselves were you
know scratching ourselves we sweat I'm
in Texas it's 110 degrees in the summer
all the time so there is this element
sometimes we have to dig trenches with
shovels and like you know it can be
grueling at times sure but the cool
thing about being electrician is that
there's so many different environments
so many different kinds of electricians
that one of them may never do anything
that any of the others do because
there's so many different kinds of work
so to say you shouldn't you wouldn't be
good for being an electricians not
actually a good question saying like you
would be really good for residential
construction because you like building
things and you like us that it's let's
change the question let's change the
question why would you like residential
work okay if you like residential like I
do very large custom homes so you're
talking like 10,000 square feet 40,000
square feet like multi
multi-million dollar mansions so being
able to see what the better half how
they live is really cool and being able
to you know like wire a place that its
basement is a carb use iam book like
just see swanky stuff and then you have
these chandeliers that are like $20,000
chandeliers that you have to try to
figure out how am I gonna engineer this
entryway so that this thing never falls
down and and just like the work that you
do being very clean and precise and
aesthetically pleasing there's some
people that are artistic in nature like
I am love doing real fine work like that
I say but there's people that I work
with that hate it they're like I can't
stand putting in these ceiling fans and
if I ever installed another ceiling fan
and like throw a wrench at somebody you
know like put me on a commercial job
we're all I got to do is bend pipe and
pull wire through a you know pipe every
day or they like the logic of lighting
control systems and making motors work a
whole different type of work there's
people that like doing stuff with solar
panels and installing solar panels it's
all different kinds of work I I love
that you like change the question a
little bit because I totally agree and I
can actually Roger said a similar thing
about plumbing he said look residential
jobs versus commercial jobs they're so
different they're they're almost in two
different ballparks except we just all
call them plumbing but I mean they're
totally different universes in terms of
your day to day I've got a I've got a uh
actually it's my brother-in-law he's an
HVAC and man he's in Texas and so he's
up in the attic every single day and
he's a little value is like yeah like
he's far with it I mean he like he's far
away that he loves he loves it yeah but
uh you know I mean if you're not fine
with that if you don't like doing a
scene up hm is HVAC the same as AC I
think it's the same thing right yeah
it's just heating ventilation yeah and
refrigeration so but but I mean he would
he would tell you like if you don't like
sweating every day all day like don't
pick this go go find some commercial job
where you're you're a lot less likely to
be all the way at the very tip-top in a
place full of insulation
yeah but here let me flip it on your
head even one more time my folks live up
in Minnesota it's cold a [ __ ] most of
the year and it's the opposite problem
you're like handling conduit in the that
you can't bend wire when it's freezing
that wires so cold you know so it's it's
an opposite problem they don't ever
experience the heat but it's just the
elements we work outside we don't work
in a cubicle so like that's the saving
grace is that you you get to work
outside and natural light if you smoke
cigarettes you can work and smoke a
cigarette like you it's just you feel
like you're more free of as an
individual in the kind of environment
where you're you're just moving and you
have a little bit more freedom of what
you can do with your day and you're not
just bound to one chair constantly I've
done a few internships with like the
corporate office job setting and it is
soul-crushing oh it is it is it's
unbelievable if you've never worked in a
floor which is just pure cubicles yeah
you're missing out on quite the
experience I mean like like you sit down
and you feel like a pure cog in the
machine there's that fluorescent
lighting which is just so oh dude it's
so it's like a salt it's a solid
building so with the same lighting all
day you might get in at five o'clock in
the morning and leave at five o'clock in
the evening and have never seen the
daylight do anything you don't have any
it's like being in Vegas they don't let
you know what time of day it is so that
you can just keep working everything's
the same all the time oh that's rough
yeah well the thing is is I know people
who that's what they love to do they
want an office job where they can sit
down it's the same every day they know
what they're doing they like what
they're doing they feel like they're
contributing and God bless them we need
them but don't be an electrician yeah
yeah just gonna be doing something
different okay so we covered let's see
here I think we've covered a lot of a
lot of the bases do you let me ask you
do you any do any side projects as an
electrician that you just are doing for
fun like setting up any circuits or hair
do you build stuff in your spare time I
mean I see a bunch of stuff behind you
what is all that stuff it's
like just really bizarre or old stuff
that I've collected or some stuff that
people have sent me and they're like hey
man this would look cool in your
background you know nice so yeah like
I'm always doing side work you know I I
enjoy doing what I do so much that I'll
do it till I die or tell I'd like
financially don't have to but I think
even if I retired I'd be like I kind of
want to get back into this you know
there's things that I have not done I've
only been doing this for 13 years now so
I'm still called the kid everywhere I go
there most electricians are in their 50s
you know so these are dudes that I
respect and look up to because they know
way more than me but isn't that a reason
that like kids should be getting into
the trades because there's not enough
young people I mean if you're a you're a
kid there must be a shortage of
electricians I mean there hello yeah
dude you're gonna be making so much
money like you're gonna make good good
money earlier than all your buddies
getting out of college that are gonna
flip flop and not end up doing anything
with their degree that's by this point
yeah especially if you're smart with
your money and invest it yeah oh yeah I
mean we could talk for hours about that
you could be started like I'm really
into investing and doing things with
your money because it makes all the
difference in your life makes aw purses
paying a check or you know paycheck to
paycheck barely able to make it every
single week versus actually knowing
you're good you got your Roth IRA 401k
all that stuff set up oh yeah not 401k I
don't work for a company but I'm okay
individual 401k because I am the I am
electrician you and I can do that yeah I
awesome on that crypto tip you do it you
do anything with crypto I don't do
anything with script I have a buddy
who's mining crypto right now Oh Mynah
and see mining is not something I'm into
but that's a huge thing you buy are you
Bitcoin are you anything else - I have
like 13 14 different coins that I am I
follow a crypto Chico or Chico crypto on
YouTube
dude he is the best youtuber I have
found he goes through he's kind of like
I looked at your channel I'm like ooh
you go and like talk about all the
negative all the [ __ ] that people are
doing to scam each other and like all
the [ __ ] you kind of cut through it
all this dude does the same thing but
it's for crypto so he
researches the technologies that are
being built the software and who is
doing what with who and he gives you all
the facts and tells you like these are
coins I would stay away from because
they're ripoffs and it's you know the
companies behind them are gonna fail and
and they're like scamming people and its
really cool if you're ever into that
stuff so I'll look into it I've got a
actually there's a really interesting
video by a buddy of mine Mike Wynn it
where he actually breaks down the cost
of mining crypto and he talks about why
it's not a good idea this is different
than a friend of mine who's actually is
mining crypto but the only reason he is
is because the place where he's mining
it at they have fixed electric costs and
so they can subsidize the cost of mining
crypto because the problem is is that
mining crypto is super expensive yeah as
electricity it runs yeah is he and in
the US or is he mining somewhere else
he's in the u.s. he's got some weird
situation with like some office building
where they pay like a flat rate I
guarantee you they're gonna get price
hike though cuz there's no way that
electric like this because they've
started mining like they have like four
rigs now and it's gonna go like this
and then eventually the landlord's gonna
be like nah we're gonna price hike and
then he's gonna be out of luck but uh
but but I've Mike when it said the same
thing he goes you know maybe you should
trade crypto before you actually go mine
it like like it seems like whirlen
better and bitcoins specifically there's
something happen happening which happens
every so often it's called a habit with
the rewards for miners are getting cut
in half so it's making it to the point
where being in the US and mining is not
worth it's gonna cost more in
electricity then you're gonna get
Bitcoin out of it so China is taking all
of the Bitcoin mining and so when that
happening event happens a lot of crazy
stuff happens like like exponential
curves where where your money you know
takes off and goes from $100 to like
thousands of dollars per coin so it's
something I was looking to the halving
of Bitcoin because in the next I never
know it I never just don't know how to
value Bitcoin like you can it's all
speculation and it's all information so
I started like it's you know about the
tulip the tulip craze right no it's that
okay is this all this is phenomenon that
happened
and I forget where but it was
specifically where all of a sudden
people started thinking that these
certain types of tulips were valuable
and so they started liking them up and
there was this huge tulip inflation
where everyone's buying tulips cuz they
think they're gonna become rich if they
can only get the tulips and eventually
the bubble burst and everyone realized
this way these are tulips they have no
actual like like nobody accepts them for
trade you know these problems and so it
burst and it's one of the famous
examples of how like there can be a
stereo around a product which if you're
the one left holding the bag at the end
you're really sad because you're like oh
well dammit it was based on nothing but
speculation although it seems like
there's like a technology and an
application behind Bitcoin so I that's
the thing you know enough about Bitcoin
to value it I don't know and I'm just a
safe investor man I'm like all about
like yeah the funds in my yeah 4 X 5
dude but I'm into that stuff too man
like there's a certain part of my
portfolio that I am super risk you know
like I will take on large large risk
because I'm ok with that
that chunk failing and then I've got my
super safe stuff too but with crypto if
you do look into it just understand
there's a lot of people out there
chasing crypto I want to have the coins
I wanna have the coins like Mario Luigi
it's it's not about the coins it's about
the technology it's about blockchain
technology so if you understand that an
entirely new system of software and
financing and how is this has exchanged
money between them and and they're not
being a middleman bank anymore to make
money off of you like a very
decentralized super secure honest thing
where things can't be hacked anymore
it's that it's the technology and like
Intel YouTube or like Google Facebook
all these massive massive tech companies
are building this stuff like they're
investing it yeah I know Facebook's
building like Libre I think their wallet
or something like that but just if you
guys are out there also be really
careful with this stuff there's a lot of
scams and everyone's just starting up
their coins trying to hype them up
trying to say they're valuable yeah I
would say the most reasonable one is
obviously Bitcoin it's the one with the
most like solid backing right now I know
aetherium
another one but just be careful make
sure you do
dude I'm not a financial advisor don't
listen to me at all yeah and listen to
people like my professional cynics so
that's good I think it's interesting
that we got off on this whole tangent
because I think I think sometimes trade
people get a bad rap for like oh they're
just blue-collar guys they don't know
anything but dude I mean you're a super
intelligent guy with all these passions
I think people should understand if
you're a curious guy if you like reading
if you like looking into stuff you can
still go be an electrician you can still
go work with your hands I mean in some
ways that I think it'll help you push
your curiosity forward because you're
you're working on those things day to
day yeah and so like me I don't know if
there's like a stereotype of what an
electrician looks like to anybody out
there who's not an electrician but like
I I play video games you know like I
wear a Nintendo hat I watch the Ninja
Turtles I've got a kid I have always
loved skateboarding uh you know like I'm
just a weird person I read a book
constantly I'm always reading I'm always
studying science investing like I don't
know man I'm such a bizarre person I
think I'm very uniquely Who I am I don't
fit a lot of traditional molds and I
love being an electrician and being a
construction worker but that's the
problem is I think in our society we
don't teach young children from an early
age that there are these great reputable
careers called the trades you know
electricians and welders and all these
we see these dirty guys and a lot of the
movies out there it's like these filthy
dudes that are like cat calling women
and that's what we think of as as
construction workers and I think that
the biggest problem and the biggest
hurdle that we have in our society is
getting schools to adopt trade programs
and just put trades as an option in
front of kids and say what if you wanted
to do this you know like do you like
building things do you like taking
things apart this is a valid option go
do this but the the schools don't know
that this is even a problem they just
have these very standardized tests that
have English and history
and math on them and that's it and I
think some of this can be boiled down to
what anytime you have a centralized
education you have to push people also
you have to have sort of a game plan for
everybody and for 30 probably 50 60 70
years we've been telling everybody okay
college for everyone right because
because there was a big need for like
office workers like with the info boom
you needed way more office workers than
you ever needed before
okay great college for everyone but then
all of a sudden we're not training
anybody in the trades we're not getting
one anyone out there
and so I think you're seeing this huge
really opportunity because opportunity
is a combination of both demand but also
you need a supply problem too like the
less supply you have the better you're
gonna do if you are in that field with
that niche of skills so I think there's
a really cool moment for people to like
go into a trade do really well when
nothing's when basically everything
hasn't been saturated like like if you
go into software dev right now my
brother does software engineering and I
mean he's great at it he's great at his
job he has a great job but dude its
killer right now the amount of software
kids graduating is insane and yes there
are a ton of jobs out there for software
people but it's like everyone is going
into coding right now and so especially
today the advice just go code is not as
good as it was 10 years ago
it's not especially not as good as it
was 20 years ago so so yeah I just love
giving people these alternate career
paths so I don't want to hang on too
long because I like to keep these a
little bit short but I mean any parting
thoughts with an audience that they
they've been running the scams they've
been like they've just been following
the gurus and you I mean you can totally
empathize with that tell them your
experience
I listen to the Guru's too and most of
them are [ __ ] the good gurus the
ones that are really successful and have
staying power and that have entire
careers built on being gurus is because
they have spent their lifetime honing a
craft Tony Robbins I listen to that dude
every morning it just put good [ __ ] in
my head because I'm tired of CNN and all
the negativity I listen to Tony Robbins
that man for 40 years has been talking
to people about how to change their
lives he's not some [ __ ] artist you
don't give me $500 this weekend and I'm
gonna revolutionize everything you know
like he he's all over the place all over
the internet and his [ __ ] is like stuff
your grandpa would tell you it's like
notion [ __ ] work hard like you know
don't get in your own way Gary
Vaynerchuk is another one a lot of
people don't really like Gary B because
he's real edgy but all he says work your
ass off like learn learn something spend
time when you're young years learning a
craft and then start talking about it
and trying to get you know up on these
screens and and doing what you see all
these people that you think are making
fast money they're not they're just
they're putting their nose down for 10
20 years and they're becoming really
really good at something right and
that's when the life change happens so
this quick money there's no such thing
it's all [ __ ] every time the best
money that you can make the best
opportunities like me I'm a youtuber now
I do this full-time I have two YouTube
channels when I [ __ ] love it but it
wouldn't have happened if I wouldn't
have put tools on 13 years ago and
started learning something so I know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about gonna
screw
[Music]
never shoulda tried
[Music]
or the car
[Music]